- [Instructor] You are
likely already familiar
with the relationship between
multiplication and division.
For example, we know that three times six
is equal to 18.
But another way to express
that same relationship
is to say, all right, if
three times six is 18,
then if I were to start with
18 and divide it by three,
that would be equal to six.
Or you could say something like this,
that 18 divided by,
divided by six
is equal to three.
Now we're just going to
extend this same relationship
between multiplication and division
to expressions that deal with fractions.
So for example,
if I were to tell you that 1/4 divided by,
and I'm going to color-code
it, divided by two
is equal to 1/8,
how could we express this relationship,
but using multiplication?
Well, if 1/4 divided
by two is equal to 1/8,
that means that 1/8 times
two is equal to 1/4.
Let me write this down, or
I could write it like this.
I could write that 1/4
is going to be equal to,
is going to be equal to 1/8 times two,
times two.
And we could do another example.
Let's say that I were to
walk up to you on the street
and I were to tell you that, hey, you, 42
is equal to
seven,
seven divided by 1/6.
In the future, we will learn
to compute things like this.
But just based on what you see here,
how could we express
this same relationship
between 42, seven, and 1/6,
but express it with multiplication?
Pause this video, and think about that.
Well, if 42 is equal to
seven divided by 1/6,
that means that 42 times 1/6
is equal to seven.
Let me write that down.
This is the same relationship
as saying that 42 times
1/6,
1/6 is equal
to seven.
Now let's say I walk
up to you on the street
and I were to say, all right, you,
I'm telling you that 1/4 divided by,
divided by six
is equal to some number
that we will express as t.
So can we rewrite this relationship
between 1/4, six, and t,
but instead of using
division, use multiplication?
Pause this video, and
try to think about it.
So if 1/4 divided by six is equal to t,
based on all of the
examples we've just seen,
that means that if we
were to take t times six,
we would get 1/4.
So we could write it
this way, t times six,
times six is going to be equal to 1/4.
If this isn't making sense,
I really want you to think
about how this relationship
is really just the same
relationship we saw up here.
The only new thing here is
instead of always having whole numbers,
we're having fractions
and representing some of
the numbers with letters.